on dit à total le week-end sectorielle
bigeard week-end samedi
derrière même si tintin vois tu rien
n'est pas dieu
mme obama et menacer ou sociales pizza
faux pas dimanche
j'aime ou pas j'ai parlé comme pour
ainsi qu'un tas de table
qu'est ce que je vais le passer
et mac le président actuel de la paix à
l'école
tam et mentalement
motion il y avait un chemin de campagne
juste à côté
maman m'a mené à la grande route
j'allais à l'école en camion certains
enfants ont été envoyés aux
fonctionnaires indiens
presque tous les mois je n'y suis jamais
allé à dongo
au canada 150 mille enfants amérindiens
inuits et métis ont fréquenté les
pensionnats indiens contre leur gré
arrachés à leurs parents
le choc a été brutal
on estime que plus de 6000 d'entre eux
sont morts de maladie de malnutrition
d'abus physiques de suicide ou sont
morts gelé après s'être enfui
peu de parents autochtone ont réussi à
tenir tête au gouvernement et à l'église
mais il y en a eu un
marie-jeanne et william pas pâti fêtent
cette année leur 40e anniversaire de
mariage
mais ni la maison qu'ils habitent au lac
simon est un refuge pour leurs enfants
petits enfants et aussi pour d'autres
qu'on leur a confiées au fil des ans je
les aime bien mais moi quand j'ai
commencé à regarder
aujourd'hui c'est notre truc à la maison
marie jeanne n'est jamais allé au
pensionnat cette institution fédérale
qui avait pour but de déposséder
l'enfant de sa langue de sa culture de
sa famille de son identité
mon père m'a protégé de toute faute pour
objet au passage quelques années plus
tôt le père de marie-jeanne avait voulu
garder ses garçons auprès de lui pour
qu'il puisse travailler mais la grc le
bras armé des affaires indiennes est
intervenue et l'arrêter il contrevenait
à la loi sur les indiens refusant
d'envoyer ses enfants à l'école
mon père n'a pas le choix c'est là
seulement pour la répartir et l'emmener
en prison
oui je pense qu'elle fait pour moi de
présentement pas pour l'avoir pour avoir
voulu laisser ma patrie à l'école
cette école c'est le pensionnat saint
marc de figuery près d'amos en abitibi
quand les frères et soeurs de marie
jeanne son revenu l'été suivant
il témoigne d'abus au pensionnat la
casse a été votre tournelles à l'école
de votre père était est au courant de ce
qui se passe ouais je pense qu'elle est
pour ça que ma vraiment pour palatial de
là je pense que je pense qu'avec coins
du monde avaient commencé à parler des
étudiants avaient commencé à appliquer
ce que séparément
pour sa plus jeune qui n'a que 5 ans il
a un plan pour que personne ne puisse
l'amener au pensionnat il va cacher
marie jeune dans ma tête comme un gros
gros toile un gros toi là dans le social
et avait commis un petit matelas pour
qu'hp est à l'aise il avait commis un
petit pas timide pas de faire pire
mais je pourrais quand même a promis un
bob avait quand même des petites unités
il y en avait un côté d'un en-avant pas
là mais c'est l'hommage man à l'arcadie
des fois dans la lah petit net
mais quand je regardais pas la potée de
même joyeux un autobus [ __ ] au canada
cet autobus qui tous les mois de
septembre revient chercher les enfants
et avec lui le père edmond brouillard
durant les quelques jours suivants le
père edmond brouillard qui maîtrise la
conquête fait le tour de la réserve avec
en main une liste de noms frappe aux
portes pour s'assurer que tous les
enfants sont bien partis à chaque fois
le père de marie-jeanne répond aux
prêtres que sa fille s'est enfui au lac
pédiatre h et kate olsen manille et
disait ça mon pare feux et l'avenue la
marie-jeanne needs armand par blizzard
non pas à wind comme celle du mont pas
n'ont pas encore ne dureront pas notre
nom est dû à quelques billets ne seront
pas mon poème de dos ça veut dire que
cherche la rate à y voir venir
d'elle-même et isamu pas mon père et
beau japon et savage dans son sac
il me disait juste il faut pas que
répond qu'à qu'on va t'appeler une fois
le père bouillard partie marie-jeanne
peut enfin sortir de sa cachette
ces journées elle est pas ça marche et
autour du lac où elle est en sécurité
lebel connais des poissons jeu probable
avait pourtant été j'avais pas
prométhéen pas
je pourrais bien entendu la paix je
l'appelais pejman à lescar en appel puis
je reviens je reviens dans la parlotte
pointe puis j'ai recommencé je pense de
trois fois johnny a promis au bord du
lac
le matin venu avant l'arrivée du père
oblat elle retourne se cacher ou sous
sol marie jeanne a pu vivre en algonquin
avec ses parents et grands parents
jusqu'à l'âge de 7 ans puis elle
fréquente la nouvelle école primaire du
village voisin
marie jeanne a pu échapper aux
pensionnats indiens mais par un triste
retour des choses
le pensionnat la rattraper un proche
victimes d'agressions sexuelles à saint
marc de figuery l'a agressée à son tour
parce qu'avec la crise n'a pas ça va
vous aviez gala moi je pense jarbawi tas
j'étais par les appareils au personnage
et quand même de ces cas là le ces cas
ne concernent que ce qu'ils ont été
aussi bilan lamia maison pc moi quelle
heure
c'est quoi que
moffett et mon club et qu'est ce que
c'est beau la petite marie jeanne libre
et insouciante à cesser ce jour-là
d'exister j'ai commencé à consommer je
crois savoir aux jeunes et futures
hausses du cac cash n'est fait du gosse
j'avais dit où mon père est improbable
parce qu'elle voulait pas tant que chief
bombe avait visé la veille peu moi je
n'irai pas
le matin est ce que vous avez vécu n'est
jamais avare non
bon je vais jamais dire ment pas
marie-jeanne s'est mariée très tôt à
l'âge de 14 ans elle ne consomme plus
depuis vingt trois le thé quand même
chanceuse de l'avoir parce que ça a été
mon protecteur je pense mon mari son
mari william aphatie ne lui a jamais
parlé de son séjour au pensionnat
jusqu'au jour où il a décidé de prendre
la parole devant la commission vérité et
réconciliation
musique2 quand l'abbé quoique avec ma
campagne je n'ai pas partagé ce sens son
histoire de lui qui a été abusée aussi
raconter mon histoire
tout a commencé à 19 ans au synthé de
william d'apatite se rappelle l'été
précédant son départ au pensionnat de sa
venue à premier est une rente but de
donner des leçons le mur
et ce sans pudeur pour nous attirer les
plus jeunes roulaient plus immédiat ok
tu dois attendre quoi te donner aux opa
sanaa avec ça qu'ils nous attirer des
vols ni mentale
il n'a que 5 ans lorsqu'il prend le
chemin du pensionnat de ses marques
figurant là bas chaque enfant porte
numéro le sien c'est le 71
williams a été victime d'abus répété
durant plusieurs années
il entend encore les pas dans le dortoir
la nuit ckac et moi un ces quelques
cumuls mal
je savais pas si tu crois qu il voulait
pas que ce qu'aucun homme là je remplis
le cuir
mais là n'est guère les bonbons détient
le label team
ce sac
oh
tu sais le cul commercial ça me touche
et le petit corps
william grandi avec la peur de parler le
prêtre lui ordonne de se taire il fugue
à deux reprises la police l'arrêtent
et c'est le père brouillard qui vient le
cueillir au poste 1 et il se confie à sa
grand mère une femme très croyante
mcavoy qui m'écoutez mais tu sais pas ça
ne plaît pas que tu es un peu tu te
feras ou te battre de touche m
c'était dur de comprendre à ma
grand-mère ce toolkit et des croates
avalé par lieu du printemps son père qui
est souvent absent finit un jour par le
croire où est mon parapluie pas croire
qu plus parce que ma - d'injures que je
saigne - amiens
je ne mens pas supporter normand plus
dur c'est me lire dès les dix après 6
quelques supports c'est vraiment cool
pour salomon pas pâti le choc est brutal
il faut sauver williams
à la fin de l'été le père et le fils
partent en canot pour rejoindre le camp
familial à une centaine de kilomètres de
la réserve
personne ne viendrait chercher son
garçon ici
j'avais 14 ans que j'ai commencé un menu
système à cacher
mais l'église catholique n'a pas dit son
dernier mot
le rabatteur en chef le père brouillard
toujours lui est à ses trousses pas
question de laisser un seul enfant se
sauver on craint trop l'effet
d'entraînement accompagné d'un aîné il
réussit à le retrouver au fond des bois
mon pain le problème est que par 6/10
officielle tenue puis à l'école sa place
et 7 mai aps un désaveu subi personnage
qu'est ce qu'est le prat a dit
le père lui est cher
comme se disent inquiets modestes et
pauvres est assez afférents qui se
passait la baule ce dimanche selon moi
par les jeunes internet on peut
bush plus près qu'est ce qui a fait le
pari est tenu
j'avais les bras
c'est parti doucement
d'abord vous êtes si quand vous l'avez
fait partie du show la perte de mon père
ma soeur il a milité contre eux pour
pouvoir y faire ma compagne de jacques
la pratique est là que j'appelais de mon
père qui m'a plu
c'est expliqué mbaye était capable de
faire un tel geste diffuseur authority a
religieusement
je me suis beaucoup
le père raymond brouille à rationner
l'abitibi pendant des années pour
s'assurer que tous les enfants prennent
le chemin du pensionnat de
st-marc-de-figuery on a compris plus
tard cet acharnement
en 1996 il a été condamné à cinq ans de
prison pour attentat à la pudeur
attouchements sexuels agressions
sexuelles et grossière indécence ses
victimes
si jeune autochtone originaire du lac
simon et du grand lac victoria
williams et marie-jeanne auront eu au
moins la chance de lui échapper
quant aux frères qui a agressé williams
il n'a jamais été inquiété
son nom revient pourtant à plusieurs
reprises dans le récit de nombreux
pensionnaires
le pensionnat de st-marc-de-figuery a
fermé ses portes en 1973
kerry de cadeaux ouais
une réserve de la nation la coda en
saskatchewan
la famille de linda kaka kaori série
unis elle attend de la grande visite
lita caudrine 90 ans vient de parcourir
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres pour
retrouver une petite amérindienne
qu'elle n'a pas vu depuis 60 ans
on
ans
lyndia cacahouète à 5 ans lorsque son
père meurt ça mais rémy devenue veuve
doit chercher du travail et surtout un
endroit pour mettre à l'abri sa petite
lyndia le père de amy qui a connu la
dureté des pensionnats la prévenue il ne
faut surtout pas que cette petite fille
connaisse le même sort
car en vivant avec sa mère monoparentale
est sans emploi
lydia devienne candidate de choix pour
le pensionnat
les enfants de familles vulnérables de
familles nomades ou semi nomades sont
particulièrement ciblés pour amy il est
impensable qu'on lui enlève de force sa
fille nine aux ouailles
je sais aujourd'hui pourquoi on habitait
chez les cousines maman avait demandé à
madame goodwin l'état de l'aider pour
qu'elle puisse garder avec elle elle
devait penser que puisque madame goodwin
n'était pas indienne les autorités ne la
remettrait pas en question donc et lui a
demandé son aide
elle voulait me garder avec elle sur un
an et demi
la famille goodwin rézé tout près de la
réserve le mari d'amy a déjà travaillé
pour eux à son tour émis leur offre ses
services d aide ménagère
emi sa fille lydia séjourneront chez les
goodwin deux ans
deux années déterminantes qui
protégeront la petite du pensionnat
la crainte des miss et que sa fille
unique soit envoyé ici à le bret
pensionnats catholiques
l'un des plus vieux au pays comme les
autres il a été le théâtre de nombreux
abus cette photo du pensionnat et de ses
tipis illustre bien le désarroi des
parents qui campent aux portes de
l'école ils ont abandonné leur vie
nomade pour se rapprocher de leurs
enfants mais on leur interdit l'entrée
au lieu de cette vie coupée des siens
lydia puis vivre paisiblement auprès de
sa mère dans la maison des goodwill
les tags audouy ne vit aujourd'hui en
alberta elle a tenu à faire tout ce
trajet pour revoir les médias elle est
accompagnée de ses deux filles
bonjour india tu te souviens tu es noir
mais messi
des états
oh
j'ai toujours pensé à vous à tout ce que
vous avez fait pour nous furet ou ses
chantiers on se rendait pas compte qu'on
fasse de bonnes actions à la baisse
lydia lui présente quelques-uns de ses
huit enfants une famille heureuse et
émue
sur le patio on parle on échange des
photos en bsb et souvenirs remontent
je me souviens j'étais assise à côté de
ses blocs de verre quand maman nous a
annoncé qu'une dame et sa petite fille
venant habiter avec nous à rillieux
stopper le dark maman disait toujours
combien les goodwin nous avait aidés
parce que nous nous sommes demandés sur
notre place pour eux cette pièce on a
tenu
près du village pourquoi vous venez
habiter chez nous non c'est bien ce que
je pensais est à une petite fille très
heureux
ensemble elle décide de revoir la maison
où elle a vécu avec sa mère aujourd'hui
décédée
et ce soir aux élèves tu nous vivions
sous sol j'avais ma propre chambre
c'est un tout petit elle nous a aidés on
était en sécurité sans aucun souci maman
devait être rassurés quand on habitait
ici un qui dit merci
ce fut un plaisir on ici heureux de
savoir tout ce que ça représente et
pauvres
j'ai la chance de vous le dire en
personne je suis heureux de rencontrer
la femme que tu es devenu lyndia pourra
fréquenter par la suite d'une école à
l'extérieur de la réserve une école de
blanc qui accepte désormais les enfants
autochtones
pour qu'elles puissent y aller sa mère a
trouvé quelqu'un de confiance pour la
conduire dans la ville voisine de
campagne
juste à côté maman m'a mené à la grande
muette 3000 da alloués ont marché
ensemble jusqu'à la route pour que je me
rende à l'école
la fin de la journée elle m'attendait
sur le bord du chemin
c'était important pour elle elle n'avait
jamais eu cette chance maintenant que je
comprends tout histoire
je trouve incroyable ce qui a fait ma
grand mère elle savait exactement ce
qu'elle faisait
je suis reconnaissante envers ma
grand-mère pour ce qu'elle a fait j'ai
du mal à imaginer comme ma vie serait
différente si elle n'avait pas fait ce
qu'est la fiscalité ou achille m
pessamit d' une réserve il ou sur la
côte nord face au fleuve saint laurent
ici aussi les enfants sont montés à bord
d'autobus jambes
leur destination le pensionnat de
sept-îles à 300 km de chez eux
robert dominique et son neveu grégoire
canapé rêvé d'aller au pensionnat comme
les autres enfants nous les avons
rencontrés dans la tente familiale la
seule sur la réserve qu'un robert
dominic adiyiah son père son désir de
partir la réponse a été très clair il ya
un époque questionnement faire garçons
et on était plusieurs autour de la table
ai dit écoutez moi bien noté les filles
les garçons et a personne qui va partir
du site
je suis là pour vous nourrir aux élevé
il y avait personne qui va partir du
site
le
et
20 ou le 21 juin l'autobus scolaire
arrive tout le monde descend avec une
petite valise les y trouver changée
et puis il parlait presque pu le noter
ainsi l'aide par les noms avaient changé
le père de robert travailler en forêt il
était garde de feu y a personne qui est
venu nous chercher mon père l'avait
beaucoup d'influx ans il parlait très
bien français
c'est peut-être pour ça que personne
n'est venu nous charger ce fut mon père
était quand même aussi influent et avait
été chef des ltte
et puis je pense que j'ose y avait comme
un droit de parole plus élevé que les
autres
si vous voulez pas cogner je crois
qu'ils avaient des doutes
1 je crois que j'avais un doute mais
dans ces années là c'est un sujet tabou
de parler compter ces six hommes de dieu
1 le gouvernement et tous
aujourd'hui grégoire organise des
séances de guérison avec ses amis
d'enfance qui sont allés au pensionnat
l'heureux moi il est un grand défenseur
de la langue et de la culture et nous
la résistance amérindienne une histoire
méconnue ou des individus en risquer le
tout pour le tout où des familles ont
défié l'église et l'agent des affaires
indiennes ou des communautés entières ou
s'ils se sont déplacés pour protéger
leurs enfants des pensionnats
c'est le cas entre autres des innu de
paco chipie sur la côte nord est des
fautes et logis bruit en alberta qu'on
appelait les rangs 2
les médinas fortifiées je ne savais pas
que des gens avaient fait tout leur
possible pour que leur enfant n'est pas
au pensionnat choses formidables
je trouve aussi que cette réunion arrive
au bon moment puisque le rapport vérité
et réconciliation vient de sortir il
raconte des histoires très rétro un bon
danseur
il
irene a trahi sembler aujourd'hui on
apprend qu'à une époque où le racisme
était endémique de se passer aussi de
berkshire mi-août une famille a accepté
d'aider ma mère et ma grand-mère à des
nationaux sans eux je ne sais pas si
nous serions là aujourd'hui c'est une
belle histoire nice surtout un site à
destroy espace rive
mortal jean michel lamarre c'est
pourquoi je suis pas état des lieux
l'homme apparaît que je l'apprécié
beaucoup
oh merde où sont d'abord peux pas dire à
tes parents tu l'as été invité par mois
mais des enfants aillent chez clymène
projets sont fiers de moi je t'aime vous
mais avant
c'est vraiment spécial qui masque les
mauvais a fait la même ni 7
puis parce que qu'ils avaient compris
les méchants ce que que je ne vais pas
chaque année
à
que